you were at jak masz speech where he
outlined some pretty audacious visions
for the company to be bigger than even
walmart in the next ten years what a
jack ma promise and do you think it's
obtainable bigger than even walmart is
what he said now remember Alibaba had
three hundred ninety billion in u.s.
dollar in gross merchandise volume last
year it's a little bit different of a
number than Walmart sales number four
hundred eighty-five billion but it's
safe to say that that's a number he's
aiming for and he says he can probably
do that in 2015 so what he's really
selling here is pitching to US
businesses to sell through Alibaba into
consumers in China and that is how he's
projecting he can be bigger than what's
known as the retail giant here in the
States Duncan I was very interested by
how Jack Ma outlined the international
opportunity for Alibaba he basically
described it in terms of cross-border
commerce so American companies but
selling to the Chinese middle class how
surprising was that to you you know
considering people have been expecting
Alibaba to kind of go the other way and
come to the u.s. and sell to American
consumers well you know I think he's
pretty cautious in the sense that we've
seen some of the failures frankly some
Chinese companies who have rushed into
the US market down in Portland Oregon
there was a you know leaning tried to
set up right opposite nike and this you
know grand scheme and it didn't work so
you know I think he's right in the sense
that the Chinese consumer market is
growing the fastest they they're going
to play to their strengths there from
here in Washington state you know
cherries have been been exported in the
pallet load by air freight to consumers
on team also you know there's a clear
demand and there's a clear supply and
he's focusing on that first it's not to
mean not to say he's not going to be
ambitious about the US later right to
that point crid alibaba has been a major
investor in US companies I mean from
snapchat to lift to zoo lily to the new
e-commerce marketplace in the u.s.
gedcom wait what our ally Baba's
ambitions when it comes to the u.s. is
it just as Jack seemed to outline today
a cross-border commerce opportunity
absolutely not and we've spoken on this
show before Jack Ma and Alibaba
replacing some very very strategic butts
and not just in u.s. investments in
summers but also in mobile users such as
the investment in snapchat and also
let's not forget video and personal
finance they're putting bets everywhere
the near trim focus of more commerce
into China is really about next quarter
and there may be the quarter after or
the remainder of the year's revenue
these longer-term bets I think will play
out and will contribute your future
revenue and Duncan how important is the
international expansion considering the
Chinese economy according to some
accounts is slowing down in terms of
growth no I agree with that point I
think firstly the international
investments are strategic for China as
well don't forget they're involved in a
very intense competition with ten cent
in mobile which is expending a lot of
their mobile investments also with JD in
the domestic ecommerce market so the
first line of defense is offense so
invest in US companies that can help
them at home but also absolutely I agree
that they are looking to the long-term
to place bets here but it's you know
it's kind of the Chinese strategy of
biding your time they're definitely busy
here but they're there they're very busy
in China right now with the competition
so Jack Ma today also addressed
counterfeiting saying Alibaba is doing
everything it can to stop it Alex do you
think this makes us companies hesitant
to work with Alibaba are they more
comfortable now considering what they
heard from Jack I mean with with the the
suit that's outstanding against Ali Baba
right now it does make us companies take
pause and I think that's a little bit of
jak masz strategy here and getting into
the US and slowly knowing the US
consumer he was extremely impassioned
today talking about what Alibaba is done
to bring that counterfeit number down to
only one out of eight eight hundred and
sixty thousand transactions which he
says this smaller than the the market in
general so he's really trying to tackle
some of these things but you know inside
the US it can be a bit of an echo
chamber and when you have a company
coming from a country that US consumers
are not as comfortable with that might
be one of the hiccups and one of the
reasons he's taking a more measured
approach in terms of getting into
selling to us buyers so Jack today also
predicted that many US Internet
companies will find success in China
over the next ten years crib for Google
you were a part of this
battlefield you know do you think Jack's
right the US Internet companies will
start to have more success and how how
involves could Alibaba be and making
that happen hugely I could certainly say
that someone likable and many others
including the company I'm with now Jonah
mobile will love to partner with someone
like an Ali Baba because now they have
tremendous reach they have solved a lot
of really tough issues we believe that
they have actually quite good
relationships with the government at all
levels and they have cloud computing
services which is perfect for an
Internet companies infrastructure so
they would be absolutely a great ally to
allow the reverse to happen which was
not yet seen which is American companies
be successful in China